hey youtubers is Charlie this week we
got another double episode Legend of
Korra episode 6 and 7 the first one was
the conclusion of the beifong
metalbending clans story and the second
episode was the beginning of a new
Airbender arc up at the northern temple
who almost threw up in their mouths when
we learned the final fate of the earth
Kings bear Bosco I'm not a PETA member
or anything like that but something
about sky bison jackets makes me so
angry hello any new people if you're
finding me for the first time I do
weekly Korra videos be sure to subscribe
to get everything
I'm even doing a special Comic Con
giveaway that I'll explain at the end of
this video so since this covers two
videos I'm going to do top 10 WTF
moments and then I'll do my review
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet I'll wait just a
second
okay ready here we go number 10 beifong
acupuncture this was the climax of the
beifong beifong episode I was really
satisfied with the way they explained
Lin's hatred of su Yin even if they did
skip a lot of things like top
mysteriously retiring and Lin just never
agreed to see her again
it sounds like Toph was pretty active in
everyone's lives up to the events of
Legend of Korra she was around while
opal was growing up so I know a lot of
you are still confused but she isn't
dead Toph is just listed as whereabouts
unknown there is no promise that she's
going to be back this year but it's
possible they could bring her back in
the comics but number 9 Bolin versus
metalbending it was awesome to see Korra
pick it up so fast I don't know that I
believe she's the first avatar to ever
metalbend it's possible but de su Yin
really know the complete history of the
avatar lineage I don't think so
based on the language that su Yin was
using I feel like the show was teasing
us that he is going to learn how to do
it by the end of this season the show is
moving pretty fast so I actually
wouldn't be surprised if it happened the
next one or two episodes his path to
metal bending and overcoming his
self-doubt is just like opal so I think
they're both gonna achieve their bending
goals at the same time it would totally
be awesome to see them do some sort of
like metal air combo move during a
battle like classic fire ferrets combo
moving on to number 8 brand new beifong
it took me a minute to get used to the
new Lin beifong kills movie did kind of
make me hungry she's not super hippie
dippie or anything now she's just
mellowed out she used to remind me of
early Toph just punching her problems
away but now she's acting like a real
adult I think the thing that
really threw me off was that smile when
she stepped out of her room did anyone
else get a Judy vibe from last airbender
like she was almost too Pleasant
something was up I actually don't think
anything's Funky's going on though I
think she just took her grumpy pants off
but number seven Lin versus sue yen
battle royale I like that they gave this
match the same emotional weight in
brutality you'd see with Aang and Fire
Lord Ozai or Azula and Zuko no-one was
pulling any punches but I mean if they
really wanted to hurt each other they'd
probably be exclusively metalbending
the kind of blunt-force trauma you do
with those big rocks is really hard to
do sneak attacks with so if they were
gonna try and be like really
unpredictable they would be using like
metal cables or projectiles it was like
a good old-fashioned street brawl like
you'd see in a classic western movie
which is kind of funny because Bumi's
Airbender Posse felt like it was
straight out of a John Wayne movie I do
think it was really cool did they let
opal be the voice of reason and stop
their fight airbending is all about
peace and tranquility so of course the
best mediators are going to be
airbenders I did see a really
interesting opal theory that you guys
were putting out in some of my videos
last week that opal is secretly the
daughter of Lin beifong I don't think
that's the case but I think going
forward auntie Lin is going to be a much
bigger part of the BEI Fong family but
number six Bumi tells Tenzin to go all
full-metal-jacket on the recruits I love
listening to JK Simmons do his best our
lee Ermey impression when it's actually
meelo that's the crazy drill sergeant
even though the episode was all
airbenders it did feel like Tenzin was
the least important person it felt like
the episode was really about the
airbenders coming together as a group
there was this one thing he said though
that struck me as possibly really
important for the future at the
beginning of the obstacle course he said
the key is to maintain your heaven and
earth connection because the guru
laghima pendant got a name drop early in
the episode I just feel like they're
trying to tee up some sort of team
Zaheer plot that they're trying to learn
some special Zen technique of lahee m'as
but number 5 Airbender Ninja Warrior
obstacle course
this was just too much fun I don't watch
American Ninja Warrior a lot but just
the idea of an obstacle course sounds
awesome and meelo with a watermelon gun
and that evil evil smile I totally have
to have a watermelon gun in my next
party now I'm Way too old for summer
camp now but did any of you ever do an
obstacle course at summer camp
had to do one as crazy as the Airbender
won but there were these monkey bars
that hung over a pool we had to get
across it was pretty crazy but this is
really all just teeing up the Jinora
story onto number four Jinora wants her
tattoos her argument Takei was that she
has attained mastery over airbending and
the subform as well as having a deep
connection to the spirits but without
the tattoos you're just a pretender I
read somewhere that in Russian prisons
traditionally having tattoos is like a
really big deal it's like it tells your
life story so the more tattoos you have
it means the more things that you've
done so if you ran into someone with no
tattoos it means there are nobody like
they're less than nothing just because
they have no life story automatically
there are a lot of cultures that use
markings like tattoos as a way to denote
mastery or maturity and even though I
think that Jinora will be a full master
by the end of this season I don't think
she's going to get her tattoos yet
avatar yang Chen is the most notable
female Airbender master that I could
think of that's pretty much what a
grown-up Jinora would look like they
don't completely shave their heads like
the men but I wouldn't be surprised if
by book 4 we saw like a more grown-up
Jinora with a shaved head but number 3
team Zaheer uses the chakras to find
Korra lava bending escape for the win
I love how Zaheer used guru Pathik
chakra technique of going to that astral
state of meditation you know where you
can sense the energy of other beings
he clearly has done his homework so I
think there are a couple likely outcomes
that he's looking to achieve either he's
trying to just straight-up bring back
guru laghima somehow or energy Bend
himself into cores body or achieve some
secret technique of lahee m'as that we
haven't seen yet either way it
definitely has something to do with guru
laghima the two-part finale is called
Enter the Void and venom of the Red
Lotus a name like the void just makes me
think of the astral state you know
whenever Aang and Korra were learning to
energy Bend right now we're only about
halfway through the season so we still
don't quite know what's a here is trying
to achieve but number two baby sky-bison
rescue I love watching Bumi rally the
other airbenders and all those wild sky
bison that zoomed in to rescue the
others I actually did think Jinora is
gonna get kidnapped for a minute did
anyone else feel like Bumi and boom-boom
were a joke making fun of Han Solo and
Chewbacca in Star Wars like when the
other bender called Bumi on being able
to speak the same language as boom Zhu
and he just waved his hand and trailed
off I feel like that totally describes
Han Solo and Chewbacca's communication I
already had a feeling that the wild sky
bison were gonna be a big part of the
plot my first three though was before
the end of the episode meelo would just
do his crazy animal whispering trick and
tain them all in like 15 minutes
let me know if you think that he could
actually do that but it's a moot point
because they're pretty much pacified
which means that we're gonna have to
have a sky bison tutorial episode but my
number one WTF moment the earth Queen
ate her father's pet bear Bosco this
made me a little upset or maybe a lot
upset because yes it's supposed to be a
joke but she's just crazy enough to do
something like that and sky bison viel
that's just enough to make anyone go
vegan and I only noticed it when they
were kicking his ass but the leader the
one that sounded like long fen you know
play by Clancy Brown his voice sounded
similar I don't think it was him but he
was wearing a sky bison Pelt Kai's
takedown was probably intended to be
Tenzin Kai moment of clarity but I
really wanted kite to go too far and
stab him with that glider stick in
defense of the episode that would be a
giant left turn for Airbender philosophy
but it would look really cool kai is a
really proficient vendor so I'm
wondering if he's gonna learn generous
spirit bending technique by the end of
the season but now it's your turn let me
know in the comments below what was your
biggest WTF moment and do you really
think that the earth Queen ate Bosco I
think she's just crazy enough to do it
given all the other exotic animals that
she eats overall I gave em sowed 6 of B+
in episode 7 and a - I just thought that
the Airbender episode moved the real
plot forward in a much better way the
guru laghima story along with team
Zaheer they were like the connective
tissue between the episodes and even
though the episodes were from like
separate two-parters I didn't feel too
disconnected I cannot wait to see bolin
metalbend I feel like he deserves it he
and Bumi are totally waving the Korra
class clown flag but I feel like both of
them get some really good hero moments I
feel like we should try to make Bolin
clenching a hashtag though seriously
Bumi speech was probably one of the
better course speeches that I've heard
this season and then to pay off the
family of a bit with him feeling like
part of the family finally in the air
nation which is really important I feel
like that was a really good moment I'm
really interested to see effets ever
shaves his head because that would
really be like the next step in his
commitment
it's like if you really intend to be
part of the air nation you would shave
your head
speaking of bald a lot of people are
actually commenting on the similarities
between Chi and Aang I do think they
share a lot of DNA on a character level
but I don't think that Kai's backstory
is going to overlap with the avatars
that much it might overlap with teams of
here's a little bit sometimes details
like that just get dropped those so if
it turns out to be nothing I'm not going
to be super disappointed it is possible
that team Zaheer have some sort of
familial connection with the main
characters I know everyone really wanted
Zaheer in pilot to be related tamaco and
Bolin but go ahead and just let me know
what your craziest team Zaheer theories
are so here's the details on my Comic
Con giveaway - if you didn't see earlier
I'm giving away a Pabu plush doll this
is in addition to the regular giveaway
so all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment I will be
a Comic Con so I'll be uploading the
Korra panel that's going to be next
Friday there are going to be two new
episodes next Friday so because it's
going to be so crazy for me that weekend
I'll try to get that video ad as soon as
possible but it might be a Saturday
morning before that happens so in the
meantime click here to learn all about
the airbending sub forum and click here
to get my episode 4 or 5 video thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow